My dad hopped on a 10 hour flight
all the way from Germany
to spend the next two weeks with me and the babies.
Lucky's out of town for two weeks,
but maybe even two months.
We don't know yet.
So since my dad arrived the night before,
he stocked me up on my favorite treats and snacks,
and also some German flour.
First thing I did was make myself some tea.
He also brought all of my favorite tea,
so I obviously had to use that.
And then it was time to make some breakfast.
Since I had this flower,
I decided to make a super nostalgic
pancake recipe to us.
I had this all the time growing up,
so it felt good having it again after a while.
I usually put applesauce on these pancakes.
Sometimes jam,
but usually applesauce.
So I made the kids one,
rolled it up,
and then they also had some clementines with that
while they were having their breakfast.
I made myself some breakfast
and then also did my morning scriptures,
wrote my to do list,
did my journaling,
and also updated a few substack things.
This part of my morning is so crucial
because if I don't do it,
it feels like I'm kind of behind in a way.
I don't know what it is.
And then I went upstairs,
did my skincare.
I could not talk about this hyaluronic
acid serum enough.
It's so good.
I also ran out of my Favorite facial oil,
which is always a bad sign
because my skin is always kind of dry when I
don't use it.
Hopped on my jewelry for the day
and then started on my hair.
Halfway through
people came to pick up our Christmas tree
cause it was time for it to go.
My dad did not wanna pay these guys.
I think it's the German in him.
So he suggested going to Home Depot
and getting a saw to do it ourselves,
but I just couldn't be bothered with that,
so I just let them pick it up.
And then made the bed,
got dressed,
and then we had errands to run,
so I obviously had to get the kids dressed
and in the car,
which is always a struggle,
but we made it.
The first stop was FedEx to.
Actually I think it was UPS
to drop off a package.
And then we went to target
because I didn't realize that it
was Slim's birthday tomorrow
and I hadn't gotten anything yet.
I'm also the most indecisive person,
so this took quite a while.
But I got some wrapping paper
that I thought was really cute.
And then our last stop was Whole Foods.
I just picked up some essentials.
I didn't do a full on groceries shop.
Also, this is my favorite gluten free pasta.
And then also this.
Smoked sea salt is the best on tomatoes.